[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today i've been looking forward to for
some time although he may not know that
this is richard wiseman who holds
britain's only professorship in the
public understanding of psychology at
the university of hertfordshire maybe
getting that right he has published more
than 100 peer-reviewed articles
examining the psychology of magic and
illusion the paranormal luck and
self-help his books on psychology which
include the luck factor the scientific
study of the lucky mind and 59 seconds
think a little change a lot have sold
more than 3 million copies worldwide and
his psychology-based youtube videos
which i highly recommend have garnered
more than 500 million views
elizabeth loftus i hope i'm getting that
right we'll find out which corrections i
need to make former president of the
association of psychological science
described richard as quote one of the
world's most creative psychologists and
quote and the independent on sunday
chose him as one of the top 100 people
who make britain a better place to live
in addition to his work in the field of
psychology richard served as director of
the edinburgh fringe festival for eight
years you can find him on twitter at
richard wiseman w-i-s-e-m-a-n
richard it's nice to see you and thank
you for taking the time today a pleasure
to be here i can i hope i can live up to
that wonderful introduction thank you
very much
so i i will ask just out of curiosity
since i do not know before we dive in
to
the meat and potatoes maybe of the
conversation what is the fringe festival
oh the edinburgh fringe is the largest
arts festival in the world
so it's it takes place
something i should know i suppose well
maybe not it takes place throughout the
whole of um
august in edinburgh and yeah i think
it's about sort of 20 000 shows or so
performed and it's huge so it's it's
everything it's drama it's music it's
magic it's cabaret and everyone should
come it's it's wonderful
wow
you know my only this is self-indulgent
to tell this story but my my memory of
edinburgh a few
a few memories and i say a few because i
think i put myself into a diabetic coma
by having several kilos of fudge which i
didn't know
was a thing and bro i went there for an
all blacks game with a friend who was a
huge rugby player from new zealand and i
had a lot of fudge went into this
fever dream of some type ended up at i
want to say the cafe where jk rowling
wrote
the first in this in the series of harry
potter it was a great visit but i don't
remember all too much so maybe i'll get
back to the festival to hop from that in
a very
lateral segway i want to describe how i
came across you and your name
so the first time it was a subconscious
imprint i'll come back to what the hell
that means then i was reading a piece
on let me pull it up here
slate star codex and the piece is called
the control group is out of control
which is recommended to be by my brother
who has a phd in statistics and he said
this is one of the best
primers or primers if people prefer
on statistics and some of the subtleties
that he's seen for lay people so i read
this
and your name came up and there was a
link to a resource
and a paper on your website that i'm
definitely going to want to dig into in
a second
called experimenter effects and the
remote detection of staring so we're
going to come back to that but your name
popped up in this and then i was showing
a friend of mine
a trailer for one of my favorite
documentaries which is an honest liar
about the amazing randy
and you also pop up in that trailer and
i said i think i recognized that name so
it being the second time i'd seen it i
connected
two and two and i thought you know i
really should have
richard on the podcast to discuss many
many different things and let's start
with
this
this paper could you provide people
listening with some background on that
we're going to flash backwards and
forwards chronologically but if you
don't mind let's start with that paper
we certainly can i mean it's quite a few
years ago now so one of the downsides to
doing things for a long time is is
remembering what you've done quite
frankly so uh yes that that was um many
years ago i think in the late 90s and it
was this so i've been involved in
parapsychology for a long time my let's
go back a little bit more i i did i
originally worked as a magician and
doing tricks for people because of that
i got fascinated with the paranormal uh
because magicians are sort of faking
paranormal stuff all the time and by
chance i did my degree at um university
college london i was walking along in my
final year walking along one of the
corridors and i saw this poster back
then email didn't exist so it's a poster
and it said um opportunity to do a phd
uh up at university of edinburgh in
parapsychology the psychology of the
paranormal and i got in touch uh with uh
professor robert morris who's head of
the unit at that point and said look i'm
skeptical about this stuff i'm a
magician i don't think any of this stuff
is true i'm either sort of person you
want he said absolutely it'd be great to
have another perspective so i came up
here worked for four years on this phd
about skepticism and and uh paranormal
and then i went to university of
hertfordshire which i still am all these
years later and was doing experiments
like the one that you're talking about
there
and so that particular study was looking
at the remote detection of staring which
is this idea we all had that someone's
staring at you you turn around and see
them behind you
and we wanted to see whether there was
experimental evidence for this
so we'd put people into the lab we'd
monitor their physiology we'd have a
video camera in front of them that fed
out to another room and at random times
an experimenter would stare at their
image and try and affect their
physiology
and to make it really interesting i was
running half the trials the other half
were being run by a colleague of mine
marilyn schlitz who's a big believer in
the paranormal and what we found was
that on her trial she got a significant
effect on mine we didn't
and so this is evidence of an
experimental effect which you get all
over psychology all over science which
is that the experimenter seems to be
imposing their thoughts and wishes and
beliefs uh on the the experiment itself
so he got a lot of of airplay uh and
that was one of the initial studies we
then tried to replicate it and didn't
get anything at all so we did a much
larger study
and complete washout complete null
results
but because of that i got involved in in
some of those debates about replication
and of course that's become a very hot
topic in science recently again because
of parapsychology so daryl bear my
colleague of mine published a study
which was
apparently showing that people could see
into the future it's a precognition
study i tried to replicate it couldn't
and then other people looked at his work
and found all sorts of problems with it
and and so for example as a scientist
when you run an experiment you're not
supposed to look at your results and
then decide how to analyze your data and
and he was doing that type of thing
and so that got criticized and then
another group of scientists said hold on
a second this may be true of
parapsychology but it's also true of
psychology and and so they started
trying to replicate mainstream
psychological findings and and some of
those failed to replicate as well so now
there's this big movement towards trying
to increase the quality of psychological
research and that the the kind of
the catalyst for that bizarrely is
parapsychology and so it's a great
example of how you start off doing one
thing and end up in a completely
different place having you know effects
that you just thought you never have
when you saw that poster initially
well i suppose you you answered it in
part by by
by describing that initial conversation
and saying that you were skeptic and
largely or completely didn't believe in
these things as someone who practiced
magic and
was
developing the ability to create these
illusions
why would you dedicate
so much time
to that study i suppose what i'm what
i'm alluding to is it's it would seem
unusual for someone to dedicate that
amount of time
to
disproving or engaging in something that
they're largely skeptical of not to say
you shouldn't i'm just curious what the
internal drivers were for you it's a
good question i mean most of my research
was looking at why people believe this
stuff which i find endlessly fascinating
and how they get fooled by magicians
which is incredibly complicated
psychology
i think the real answer though in terms
of doing the experimental work
is this just really interesting it's
really fun i mean i i could i could be
running a really dull memory experiment
where you ask people to repeat back
strings and numbers or i could be
running a parapsychology experiment
which is lots of fun because everybody
wants to do it everyone's interested in
the results and so on
and so even now you know all these years
later i'm still skeptical about
paranormal but i still find it
fascinating i did as a kid you know
these books on ufos and bigfoot and all
this sort of stuff
and i think once you've got that passion
you just spend longer
looking at the topic you're passionate
about and you become better than
everyone else or better informed than
everyone else and so that's how you
become an expert in it
so i think that yes i was kind of
skeptical but i was also just fascinated
by the topic
so you already mentioned
your early engagement with magic but i i
want to underscore that a bit because
we should establish the bona fides the
bonafide is as they say
in my corner of the world perhaps we
could start with the magic circle
society could you explain
what that is or what it was i assume
it's still
still in existence oh yeah the circle
magic circle's based in london and uh
it's it's been going for very long time
i can remember it's formed now i think
about 1904 i think
and it's the kind of melting pot for all
of the the kind of british magicians and
so there's the magic circle there's the
inner circle which is only 300 magicians
worldwide i'm a member of the the inner
circle and magic is this incredibly
close-knit community so you can go
anywhere in the world and you'll know
other magicians and and so on so that's
what the circle is it's one of the
reasons why i ended up at university
college london is that that's very close
to where the magic circle's based
in london i i should say if other people
are choosing where to do your university
degree that's probably not the best
criteria
to be using
but i did that and then as a young man
in my sort of teens i performed
professionally i went over to the magic
castle in hollywood performed over there
amazing place it's incredible
so i love magic most of my best friends
are magicians you know i've worked with
very well-known magicians and
it's the gift that keeps on giving i i
think i was thinking about this the
other day
in part because it provides you with a
tremendous community and i think we
overlook that with hobbies and interests
is there isn't just that interest the
fact you're connecting with others
you've got a shared interest there's
people you can talk to about whatever it
is so community building community
tremendously important and magic does
that very easily
so my experience in other fields let's
just say exercise science the
practitioners in the field are often in
some respects ahead of the academicians
or the
theoreticians who are or working mostly
on papers and not with people let's just
say so if you look at olympic coaches
very often not always
but there are elements of their training
used for competitive advantage with
incredible incentives that end up being
proven out many years later in some
capacity
are there any particular disciplines
conceptual frameworks
any such advantages that you see
magicians as having that you think we're
only going to start to touch or are only
beginning to explore now or in the
forthcoming years oh yeah i mean there
is a whole psychology and science of
magic but it's very very primitive
compared to what the practitioners are
doing it's exactly what what you say you
know as a magician you have to go out in
front of a bunch of strangers and fool
them every single time it's like doing a
psychology study but the difference is
where psychology studies sometimes fail
or only work with ninety percent of
people even on a good day your
experiment your magic trick has to work
with a hundred percent of people every
single night and not only when they
watch the trick when they all go to the
bar afterwards and try and figure out
how it's done
and so magicians are really good
psychologists they have to understand
where you're going to place your
attention
how you're perceiving a particular
action you know if you're taking a coin
and one hand and and trying to convince
them uh that's really there when it
isn't how you do that the subtleties of
that
and then how they recall how they
remember a show
so
you know all these things the sorts of
skills magicians are really good at
psychologists haven't even scratched
that surface so it's absolutely as you
say practitioners in this instance way
above a way ahead of the the scientists
we're going to i'll just i like to
foreshadow a lot so forgive that
predisposition where i'm going to ask
you about mass participation studies
because i am
incredibly interested in this but before
we get to that
are there any particular magicians
illusionists mentalists whichever labels
you might want to use
who
you think are underrated or who
particularly impress you
or you look at them and you're like
wow i wish i could do that or i don't
know how they do that are there any
names
people who come to mind
there's a few different questions
sitting in there
most magic once you've been in magic a
long time doesn't fool you
and so you don't get that kind of
wondrous experience of oh my goodness i
have no idea how that just happened
because you've been around a while you
know most of the strategies and so on
so not very much magic would fool me in
terms of being impressed well the answer
is pretty much anyone who earns their
living doing magic is a really hard way
to earn your living and so if you take
you know in the vegas performers you
know penitela david copperfield
and and so on they've been doing a very
long time they're extremely good at what
what they're doing it's astonishing
their stagecraft and and so on so yeah
i'm i'm impressed all the time by anyone
who earns their living doing magic even
though i'm probably not fooled by by
what they're doing
it's the reason why magicians don't tell
you their secrets you know it's it's the
effects you know the the wondrous
effects of having showing a box empty
and a person appears in it it's a
wondrous moment if you actually saw the
method if you saw the dirty part it's so
simple and so disappointing that it just
is a huge letdown it probably means next
time you won't have that wondrous
experience so magicians withhold their
secrets actually for the good the
audience most times
that answer actually elicits maybe a
counter example not that they're
mutually exclusive but i recall one of
my first larger public speaking
engagements was that something called
the entertainment gathering which was
sort of a close cousin of ted very small
i was in
he was in monterey at the time and
teller of penn teller was there and
as people may or may not know he usually
doesn't talk
at least on stage
and he gave this presentation and almost
the entire presentation was sh he showed
this particular magic trick
where he's he's making this ball follow
his hands around and it's an incredible
sort of visual performance
then he goes into
ninety percent of the presentation is
the description of all the training and
practice that went into it and then he
shows it again he says now
are you more or less impressed after
having seen what went into it and i
think for a lot of people the answer was
more but i do think also in as you said
it's it's true that for the benefit of
the audience very often it's it's not
shared let me just talk to that for the
moment because teller is deeply
knowledgeable about magic so he isn't
just revealing the method there of the
red bull he's going through everything
everything he has to do as a performer
to make that happen and how he created
it in the first place and that's very
different i think magic becomes
fascinating at that level but that's
very different to what lots of people
expose magic do which is go oh it's a
mirror
and that and that's the end of that it's
so yeah when you pack it at the level
that teller can unpack it absolutely
it's fascinating
i want to give a few examples of of
people who impress me for different
reasons and this is as a lay person i i
have i mean you've forgotten more about
magic and illusion today than i will
learn in my entire life
uh but uh david blaine is one example
there are a lot of i've spent some time
with him i've interviewed him
and uh think what you may as he he uses
the term endurance artist for himself
which i actually think is very
appropriate because what some in the
audience might think of as a magic trick
is actually months and months of
physical training for these just
absurdly punishing physical acts right
living in ice for a period of time or
holding your breath for 17 minutes like
these aren't sort of illusions in the
usual sense of the word and then you
have somebody say like
derek delgaudio who i've never met but
we've texted a little bit i read his
book a moral man which i greatly enjoyed
and in his show in and of itself which i
highly recommend to folks i think it's
it's a
it's just a master class it's
storytelling and stage presence in a lot
of ways but
there's one piece where he walks through
the audience
and he's he's naming the cards that
people have chosen prior
spoiler alert sorry guys a little late
with spoiler alert but it won't ruin the
effect and he's he's pairing people with
the cards they chose as their identities
prior to the event and there are
hundreds of people maybe 200 people in
the audience
and
i remember watching it with someone and
they said oh my god that's such an
amazing trick
they looked at it as an illusion and for
me as someone who had read books about
harry lorraine
and these various kind of memory
kind of brute force mnemonic experts i
was like no i think i know how he's
doing it it's just mind-boggling how
quickly he's able to do it
while he's also running an entire show
right
and i'm wondering if are there any other
performances or performers who come to
mind
in that capacity
if that's even a coaching question
just uh
because i don't unders i don't know
which different species of magic exist
right i've seen performers on the street
i've seen performers on the stage but i
have to imagine it's it's somewhat like
medicine or surgery like you have
specialists
so are there any specialists who come to
mind as particularly impressive
those two that you've chosen are
wonderful examples so
what was really smart about blaine first
of all he's in doing those endurance
feats and oftentimes they're they're
genuine and absolutely terrifying
also what he did was really clever in
the first specials where he was doing
street magic which is one of the genres
now which is out there which is taking
magic away from the stage and actually
back where it started on on the streets
and what was really smart was instead of
placing the camera entirely on him doing
tricks he'd really focus it on the
audience responding to those illusions
and you saw people scream and go wow and
run down the street and all those things
and of course
those emotions then came through the
screen because you know they became
contagious emotions
and and so you got to feel how those
people felt and that was the brilliance
of of
david's early street work
derek what what he's superb at is
incorporating narrative into magic and
lots of tricks don't have any sense of
narrative they're just here's an empty
box now there's a person inside you go
that's a great puzzle but whatever what
am i supposed to be thinking and and
derek's brilliance and partly is to
really incorporate that narrative that
touches people that mean something to
people that suddenly this magic is is
far more meaningful in a much more sort
of theatrical sense
so all these things are really
interesting skill sets but to answer
your question uh there's close-up magic
street magic there's stage magic there's
mentalism there's silent magic which
would be sort of production of doves
there's manipulation with cards and
coins
it goes on and on and on and and yeah
people become very specialized in in
certain types of it
how would you define or describe
mentalism
mentalism is really the
fabrication of
mental effects so it would be
telepathy predicting the future
clairvoyance where you know somebody
shakes a dice in a cup and you tell them
what numbers have come up and whatever
so it's that side of things and then it
shades into psychological illusionism
which is where you're doing the same
sorts of things but you're saying
actually it's based on your body
language or whatever you're giving a
psychological explanation rather than a
paranormal one
so cold reading would fall into the
bucket of mentalism broadly yeah cold
reading which is where you you're often
well often starting out with very
general statements about people it's
what psychic readers do and often
they're very sort of
depend on flattery so it'll be like oh i
get the impression you've got a lot of
untapped creative potential you know
there's very few people that will go no
that's not me
at all or they're double headers you
know sometimes you like to be the life
and soul of the party other times you'd
rather stay at home
reading a book well that's true of
everyone because you just predicted both
outcomes and so you throw out these
general things and then on the basis of
their body language on how interested
they look and so on you start to sharpen
it up and you start to try and figure
out what their lives are like
and so that's that's broadly cold
reading
any names because i love
watching performances and documentaries
and reading about
performers and all the specialties that
you just mentioned
so
i don't know if you've ever seen dealt
about richard turner who i then ended up
interviewing i mean just his entire
story i don't want to spoil it for folks
but just like watch the
trailer for delt about this card
mechanic named richard turner it's
incredible are there any names i could
look up where the audience could look
into for mentalism well the obvious one
in the uk would be darren brown
darren
yes astonishing work he's been over on
broadway as well and and so yeah he's
doing a lot of that psychological stuff
and mentalism as well and because you
mentioned another
genre there which is card magic which
actually is a very big part of
close-up magic and richard turner's
wonderful and other incredible sleight
of hand people
that stuff never appealed to me quite so
much because you have to spend your
entire life with a deck of cards in your
hand and
that i i just don't have the patience
quite frankly but i'm in awe of people
that do
let's come back to what i i left a
bookmark in mass participation studies
you've carried out lots of mass
participation studies what is a mass
participation study and maybe you could
answer that by giving giving some
examples or any example that comes to
mind
as mass participation studies as the
name suggests is studies involving lots
of people
and
it was a life-changing experience for me
uh surrounding my very first one
so i got to university heart for cheer
after studying in edinburgh and i think
within a couple of weeks sitting at my
desk this email came around because
email had been invented by then uh from
the uh the bbc and they said we're we're
gonna be doing a mass participation
experiment as part of science week in
the uk
and uh we haven't got any ideas for what
we should do so we're emailing all
scientists and psychologists anyone got
any ideas
and it would have been the easiest email
to have just deleted and thought well
you know there's thousands of people
getting that but at the time i was
working on the psychology of lying
and i thought well wouldn't it be fun
to suggest that uh politicians from the
three main political parties which we
had in the uk at the time went on
television and they lied and told the
truth and then the public voted on which
they thought was the lie and we could
work out
which party had got the best liars
i sent in i sent it in it must have
taken me i'd know 30 seconds to write
that email
and it changed my life because about two
weeks later simon singh who's a
a very big author and uh mathematician
uh was working the bbc at the time
phoned me up he said i'm working on
tomorrow's world which is the tv program
that this is going to go out on and
we've chosen yours as the winning star
this is going to be a mass participation
study we're going to get the whole
country trying to detect lies
and so we contacted the political
parties said will you come on and lie
and tell the truth and they all said no
ridiculous
right so we thought this is the end of
the study and then we eventually decided
uh to
convince a very well-known political
interviewer over here at the times robin
day
i think was kind of walter cronkite
figure would be the sort of equivalent
in the states
to come and lie and tell the truth
so he goes into national television i
interview him twice once he's lying once
he's telling the truth and we open the
phone lines
and we had no idea whether like 10
people were gonna phone in or 15 we got
about 30 000 people
it was incredible in about 10 minutes
this is all in a live tv program
and so i had to look at those results as
they come in turn them around very
quickly and then interpret the results
on tv
and the uh the fact of the matter was
that when we watch people lie and tell
the truth
on video or film or tv we're really not
very good at detecting a lie and the
results supported that about 50 50. that
was chance split
uh however we'd also run two other parts
of the study we'd broadcast just the
audio on national radio and we put the
transcripts into a national newspaper
and when you focus people's attention on
the verbal cues
which is where the really good stuff is
in terms of uh signals for lying they
become much better light detectors
so that 50 percent went up to about 61
up to about 70 accuracy just when you
read the transcripts or you listen to it
on the radio because suddenly all the
ums and the r's and the lack of detail
the lack of eyes me my and so on they
all jump out at you where when you're
overwhelmed with visual information you
just don't spot that and that was my
first ever mass participation experiment
and because of that they came back to me
year after year and i invented loads of
them for them
all right i want to hear more examples
but
could you explain or elaborate on the
lack of i me mine as an indicator
with lie detection i've done quite a bit
of it over the years
what you're looking for are movements
away from what's called the baseline
we've all got a sort of signature in
terms of how much eye contact we we make
when we're talking or whether we
say the words i me mine or adjectives or
whatever
and once you've established that
baseline what you see is that liars have
a fairly consistent pattern of movement
against that baseline
so one is a lack of detail
shorter sentences
bigger response time which is the time
between the end of a question and the
beginning of an answer and also a
psychological distancing they don't like
saying me my i all those sorts of things
which wrap them up in the story
and and so it's a it's a good little
hint and tip as somebody there's
evidence that somebody might be lying to
you
what are some other
favorite mass participation studies
my goodness well the the
the famous one which haunts me to this
day
is it doesn't haunt me i love it i love
it
a few years later
we're going to have not science week but
science year in the uk
and it was being run by the british
science association and they asked me to
come up with an idea
and i did this thing which i've often
done with ideas meetings
which is that you think about it but you
don't have an idea
you don't have an idea you wait until
you walk
into the room to pitch your idea
before you have your id you leave it
until the very very last minute
and it means you either walk in full of
energy and a great idea or you walk in
with nothing and it's deeply
embarrassing
so it's it's it's neither all thing but
i i try not to have ideas until i'm
right in the room and and with people
and that's what happened here didn't
have one walked in as i walked through
the door i thought we should search for
the world's funniest joke
because that's a family-friendly
activity
it's everyone's interested in what's the
world's funniest joke everyone's got a
view on what's funny and not funny and
that's what i said i suppose family
friendly depends on the way
it depends on but it's potentially
family friendly and and potentially
utterly inappropriate so that was it it
was a one-line pitch and it was a
one-line answer they said let's do it
so i go back to the lab
and uh i said right we're going to find
the world's funniest joke and they went
great how are we going to do that and i
hadn't actually got a method unless
i said well
what we could do is set up a website to
collect data which at the time was
actually a novel idea
well not now so we set up this
specialist website people could input
jokes in one part of it and then rate
how funny they found randomly selected
jokes in the other part and we set this
up got huge amounts of media coverage
thousands of jokes coming in and the
problem came out exactly the one you
just alluded to which is some of the
jokes were a little bit rude and we
couldn't possibly allow families onto
the site to read them
and there was no way of figuring out
what's a rude joke you you can search
for certain words an algorithm but jokes
often you know
they've got symbolic meaning and so i
had to employ somebody
whose job it was full time was to
actually take out all the really rude
jokes
so they ended up i want their
compilation
they've got it they've got a compilation
of 40 000 disgusting jokes they used to
go to parties with the rudest jokes i've
ever heard
uh based on the study
so we did that and and again mass
participation i think we had a million
people take part in that study from all
around the world uh and and it was so
much fun to do it lasted 12 months as i
say and that was great so there's
another one it's called laugh lab and it
still comes up you know it still crops
up in the media and so on even though
that was i think about 2000 we did that
where to go we're gonna run out of or i
will run out of
time before
we run out of questions
there's so many different directions
that i'd like to go i'll have to pick
one
let's let's start with just a couple of
subject areas and then i'd love to hear
you expand on them and i have a few
uh
the first is because i have a note and a
queue in front of me here
nlp so neuro-linguistic programming
let's dive into that i would love any
and all perspectives again be helpful to
define terms for those who aren't
familiar
well nlp where do i start i mean it's
it's a bag of stuff as us psychologists
would refer to it it's lots of different
ideas isn't one thing i've heard nlp
referred to as nothing like psychology
and there is
maybe some truth to that for some parts
of it so i think some parts of it have
shown to be valid
i think
mirroring of mirroring where you mirror
the other person's body language and in
order to get rapport and so on there's
probably something to that
some of the the kind of verbal priming i
think there might be something to that
unfortunately there's big parts of it
that are
you know just don't work out at all
so to get back to lying there's this
notion that if you look in a certain
direction that you'll be lying and if
you look in another direction you're
telling the truth
and i can never remember which way round
is it's like up to the left is lying and
down to the right telling the truth or
something and it's a very widely
believed idea
and so a few years ago we put it to the
test so we had a bunch of students we
asked them to go into an office and
either steal a mobile phone that was in
the office or to to just put it into the
drawer and then they they came out and
they all tried to convince us that put
it into the drawer so some of them were
lying some of them were telling the
truth we could look at their eye
movements nlp didn't work out at all it
didn't matter where they were looking
and you might argue that's not a very
what psychologist would call
ecologically valid task i it's an
artificial task
so we then went to look at these very
public kind of press conferences that
the police hold sometimes in the uk when
there's been a missing persons case
where relatives come on and appeal for
the missing person
in some instances
it turns out that the person doing the
appeal is the person who's guilty of the
crime
so we know those people are lying during
that press conference
equally we know in many of the press
conferences the people were telling the
truth it was a genuine appeal so again
we could look at the eye movements again
we did it
no indication at all no hint that this
idea that certain eye movements
associated
with with lying or telling the truth so
it's very important with all of these
ideas
about psychology is to put them to the
test because otherwise you might be you
know
using some kind of tip or technique
that's got no validity at all and with
lying you know it really matters
so nlp then net net i don't know what
the sort of purported applications are
of of nlp but would you say
kind of safe discard
in terms of paying attention to it is a
developable skill
no i i would say
think about what you're trying to do
think about what the practitioners are
telling you and then look at the
academic literature to see if it holds
water
if it's a really important thing like
whether someone's telling the truth or
lying if you're just having fun
what does it matter
but but yes it's important that i would
always fall back on the academic work
because it's not just nlp there are so
many things out there which you know
everybody does based on psychology and
actually the academic work doesn't
underpin it so you know brainstorming
for example
terrible idea you know let's all get
together and kick around an idea and
come up with new ideas it doesn't work
it's not particularly effective
what's far more effective is that
everyone thinks of three ideas three
solutions to the problem before they go
into the room and you go around the
group and everyone mentions their three
ideas
because that way you don't get an
individual dominating the group and
certain ideas not getting a hearing so
again it's just really important i think
to go hold on a second if this matters
if this is important what's the evidence
which was underpinned by the 59 seconds
book
okay we're going to talk more about 59
seconds let's let's dive into the the
literature so
in the last six to eight years i've
supported or i should say more
accurately mostly my foundation is has
supported a lot of early stage science
so
basic science and also kind of clinical
applications
of various compounds and therapies at
places like johns hopkins and
ucsf actually also at imperial college
london with david nutt and formerly
robin carhart harris mostly fmri studies
and kind of head-to-head trials looking
at
standard of care antidepressants and in
this case psilocybin
so i'm deeply deeply interested in in
science
it's it's sometimes hard to get funding
for
experimentation different categories of
experimentation are there any particular
and this comes back actually also to the
the
replication problem or crisis in so much
as
if people conduct studies and get a null
result
in some cases they're disincentivized
for any number of reasons for submitting
those for publication and there's
there's a lot going on there are there
particular areas
where you
really wish there would be more
scientific study just because there is
either a lack of funding or other issues
that preclude there being much
literature at this point to even search
through
i think
i would give
a fairly generic answer to that
a lot of psychology i can only speak for
psychology i don't know any other area
of science
a lot of psychology
simply isn't relevant to people's lives
and so the way you get on and you get
you do well in as a psychologist is you
publish in certain well-respected
academic journals and you bring in
funding
but in order to do that you actually
don't have to do any research that's
especially relevant because those
journals want often theoretical papers
or their papers just a small group your
colleagues find particularly interesting
and often funding agencies are run by
you know very small numbers of people
that got very particular uh agendas
so i would say in psychology anything
that is relevant to people's lives
people have difficult lives we know that
and we know that psychology can help
them so that that's where i would always
go and a lot of psychology is very
theoretical uh it doesn't really have
any impact and and
or or any relevance so i think i would
go there if if i sort of dug down into
very particular
examples
i mean you know i i found all the sort
of
you take the whole self-help literature
go into any bookstore you know massive
numbers of self-development self-help
texts
how much psychology looks at those areas
often it's absolutely tiny you know why
some people successful other people are
why some people entrepreneurial other
people we don't know the answers to
these questions from academia because no
one looks at this stuff they're too busy
looking at you know
visual perception short-term memory or
whatever it is that doesn't really have
any relevance to anything outside the
lab so my answer would be anything
relevant to people's lives
i'm going to come back to 59 seconds but
since i i wanted to
to lead to a second
topic area after nlp i'm going to go
there first
remote viewing
one of the things i loved just to
further sell an honest liar this doc
about the amazing randy is that
and this isn't really giving anything
away if anything it's going to make
people want to see it more
randy trained
students to participate in let's just
call it
parapsychology studies and he gave
a checklist to the experimenters
that would allow them to in effect catch
his students if they follow this
checklist the whole thing is just
fascinating but let's look at remote
viewing specifically i'd love to just
have you have you define what it is
and then
explore that in any way that makes sense
to you because you know there are books
out there like phenomenon
written by journalists to explore i
think it was called stargate i may be
getting the the actual name of the
initiative wrong
within i want to say the cia
with a number of different folks from
sri and
palo alto some of them now in texas
but could you speak to this and then
go in any direction you like most and to
me what i'd love to hear is like how do
people
fake this
if that's something that you're familiar
with yeah so remote viewing is
essentially a form of clairvoyance which
is that you allegedly go to a remote
location
psychically and and tell people what's
there
and you're absolutely right stargate cia
sri all these places were working with a
small group of remote viewers primarily
for intelligence purposes
there's
not very much science that was happening
there it was very kind of
practitioner-based
and and and so they weren't really
testing those folks they were just
asking them for information from for
remote submarine bases or whatever
and some it turned out to be accurate
some of it didn't and i wrote a critique
actually of some of that work
i think in terms of people faking it i
suspect they're probably not faking it
most people who claim to be psychic
aren't fakes some are but most are not
and the reason why they're not is that
it's very easy to fool yourself into
thinking you've got these abilities when
you haven't without faking anything
so for example the closest thing that
most people experience to remote viewing
might be having a dream and then the
following day or the following week
events happen in your life that really
correspond to that dream
well how do you know whether or not your
dream predicted the future i mean for a
start you have a lot of dreams we have
four or five of them every single night
second you've got to remember the dream
and find elements of it that match
events in your real life well that's a
creativity exercise because some events
will and some events won't
and then you have to remember there's
lots of people like you on the planet so
it might be that you've like won the
lottery and there's genuine matching
there but there's millions of people who
didn't and and that pulls that right
back to chance
and the same is true of remote viewing
you know it's
you're going to have a lot of guesses
you're going to have a kind of a
creativity exercise saying well i said
it was this but actually the answer was
that do those things match or not and if
you want to believe there's patterning
there you'll find those patterns
and of course you do it again and again
and again and and sometimes you're going
to get lucky by chance and those the
sorts of things which trip people up
those those biases that we all use in
everyday life that convince them their
psychic when they're not i don't think
it's to do with conscious fakery
as it were same with cold reading most
readers most psychics most mediums are
not consciously cheating they're just
falling foul of the biases which we all
have confirmation bias and and so on
when we want to believe something
how do you choose your book subjects and
you could pick anyone that that comes to
mind you have 59 seconds certainly one
great title
paranormality
you could start with any example that
you like but we all have finite time how
do you choose
or how have you chosen
some of these subjects and why yeah so
actually
chance plays a big role so 59 i went out
i i'd written the luck factor i went out
for coffee with a friend of mine who's
the ceo of quite a big organization
and she wasn't very happy and she said
oh you understand about happiness stuff
how do you make somebody happy so i
start to explain and she looks at a
watch and says well can you get on with
it cause i'm a bit busy
and i said how long have you got
how long have you got she said i know
about a minute
and i thought can i say something in a
minute that's meaningful about happiness
i thought that's a good challenge so i
gave it a go and we came out with a
couple of things
and then i thought he has loads of
psychology that you can learn in a
minute in terms of motivational
relationships or persuasion or whatever
it is i'll gather it all together that's
a fun thing
and then so it's for for a long time
when i was working on that book it was
called 60 seconds
i then go out to give a schools talk
and there's a rather annoying young boy
at the front of this talk who's not
heckling me but you know just just isn't
enjoying the talk
and i at one point someone says what are
you working on i said it's a book about
how what you can learn in less than a
minute it's called 60 seconds and this
little boy says well it's less than a
minute it should be called 59 seconds
and i thought thank goodness you came
along and heckled boy because that's a
much better title than the one
[Music]
i've got so it's called 59 seconds uh
and then yeah the byline which is i
think a little uh changed a lot um just
came to me i was at the gym one day and
it just like bumped
came there so that that became a thing
and it's a good example i mean that
literature was out there all the time
anyone could have seen it and it just
takes that reframing to go oh my
goodness there's something sitting right
in front of us all the time that that's
kind of interesting and yeah that became
let's say 59 seconds
what about uh paranormality
because but i mean books books are a
real investment of of time and energy
how did you decide to dedicate time to
that yeah that one i mean i i obviously
carried out about 10 years of research
into the paranormal i i think
paranormality as a title was my editor's
idea and it was
really driven by the fact that if you go
to bookstores certainly over here in the
uk and you go to the paranormal section
it's all just believer stuff that's what
sells you know it's it's bigfoot's true
and ufos exists and everyone's psychic
and i thought wouldn't be great to put
out a popular book
that actually did the same as teller did
to you with the the red ball trick not
just says these things
you know aren't true but really goes
into the psychology of it why do we have
these experiences why do we see ghosts
why do we think we predicted the future
why do we go to mediums why do we have
seance phenomena and so on if it's not
true what's going on and so
paranormality is is why we believe
things aren't true and it's quite a deep
dive into the the psychology of that
based on most mostly on my own research
are there any mass participation studies
that you would have liked to or would
still like to
carry out that you haven't been able to
for whatever reason
you know not not really because i think
if i had that idea i'd uh that killer
idea i'd go and do it i mean what's
great nowadays with the web and so on is
you can do so many of these these things
but we did the first event we did a
remote viewing study on twitter we're
the first people to do an experiment on
twitter out of your account the at
richard weiss yeah years ago years ago
yeah oh okay so and we wrote it up so i
went to a remote location then asked all
my followers on twitter to try and guess
where i was and they sent in tweets and
and then we analyzed those and they
weren't particularly accurate but that
was the i believe the first social media
psychology mass participation experiment
we also did another one called the mind
machine which was a a kiosk based thing
which you put into shopping
malls and people could go up they'd
touch the screen and they'd run an esp
experiment they had to predict whether
the computer was choosing heads or tails
and we took that around shopping malls
uh in the the uk and again it's about a
million people took part in it so yeah
they're all kind of fun studies and
they're all in paranormality
so certainly i suggest people check out
the book but if you wouldn't mind
in broad strokes what happened in those
two experiments well the twitch one they
couldn't figure out where i was
and the
mind machine people guessed exactly a
chance so it wasn't exactly overwhelming
evidence that paranormal forces exist so
done that sort of thing we've done loads
of fake seances which are so much fun
and victorian times they turn out the
lights they put luminous up dots and
objects and they'd fly all over the room
and i found these books at victorian
books which you got all the secrets in
and they're often really simple and i
thought i wonder if it would fool a
modern day audience and we staged you
know endless fake seances of the country
and yes indeed it does fool people
and so on so we've done lots of fun
stuff ghost hunting we did ghost hunting
at a royal palace here we were the first
people to go into a royal palace and try
and find a ghost and we couldn't find
one surprise surprise but then we looked
at people's ghostly experiences in that
royal palace visitors as they came round
looking another mass participation
experiment and tried to figure out what
sorts of people what sorts of locations
and so on so yes it's it's a fun fun
topic to be into
were you hunting ghosts with a geiger
counter or a ghostbusters style or what
were you
who were you using well it's strange you
should ask because i did have a weird
experience
so this was at hampton court palace
which is in london and uh very famous
royal palace so go in and we're the
first people
invited into a royal palace to do ghost
hunting so lots of media attention
and there's going to be a press
conference
and there's a lot of press there a lot
of international press and the weirdest
thing happened and this has only
happened to me once in my entire life so
i'm standing there and it's a very busy
day i thought before the press
conference i'll go and get some fresh
air so i walked out
a car drove past a couple of teenagers
in it and one of them threw an egg at me
now that has never happened to me this
is the only time so this egg hits me it
splatters
and i this is the only jacket i've got
so
i go back into the press conference it
looks like ectoplasm
down the jacket
and so the journalists like oh my
goodness you've already found a ghost
like in ghost busters i said no no
someone's just throwing an egg at me
outside it was all very weird uh so yeah
we did a little bit of the ghost busting
thing that went with proton packs or
whatever they're called
we did have thermal sensors and all that
kind of stuff but primarily is about the
psychology of the situation
you mentioned dreams earlier
you're fascinated by dreaming
why are you fascinated
by dreaming because i can't believe
how much goes on
in my head when i mean think about it oh
all of our heads we fall asleep
and then you wake up
eight hours later and you don't remember
a thing you think i've been out of
action for that time and what we know is
that people are going through a very
predictable sleep cycle there's all
sorts of repair going on to the brain
and the body and then about four or five
times you go into dream sleep
and you have these really weird dreams
and what's phenomenal is the research is
now showing us that these dreams are not
random
they are our minds working through our
anxieties and our worries and trying to
either knock the edge off of some of
those anxieties or problem solve
and what i find incredible is the number
of times i have woken up with a solution
to an experiment or an idea or a book
fully formed in my head
the first thing in the morning it's
happened to me again and again
and often with magic
actually so a friend of mine was doing a
television show here
and i wasn't really thinking about it uh
when i woke up in the morning boom i got
the entire item in my head even to damn
well the camera angles were and
everything and i just find that
incredible there's so much going on
offline as it were
i share this
interest i'm reading a book right now by
matt walker why we sleep and and for
those who who are curious matt is a very
credible scientist he really
he really knows uh his neuroscience
fantastic book it goes more into the
the why and how and specifics of of
sleep
without a specific focus on dreaming but
i read a book when i was in college so
the very beginning undergrad i was
neuroscience for a period of time then
couldn't do the animal testing necessary
to work in the lab i wanted to be part
of which was with barry jacobs not
saying i oppose it completely i just
couldn't be hands-on with it at the time
and i read a book
named exploring the world of lucid
dreaming by stephen laberge
which
i found to be very practical
and i don't know if you have any
thoughts on on lucid dreaming but it
does seem like you can experimentally
demonstrate that it exists just through
iq and tracking
and you can improve it as a trainable
skill through journaling and waking up
at odd hours and doing various things
like i think mnemonic induced lucid
dreaming mild is one acronym
do you have any any experience with her
thoughts on lucid dreaming
unfortunately no i mean i i did a book
called sleep school
night school sorry can be good if i
remembered the title of my own uh book
night school uh
and sleep deprivation i haven't slept
well for years no um uh night school and
as i contacted uh stephen uh in that and
he was very gracious talking about lucid
dreaming i really wish i could do it it
sounds phenomenal i've only had one
lucid dream in my life which i woke up
and i was in a shopping mall i mean the
lucid dream
and
i was only partially in control i mean
good lucid dreamers can can do whatever
they want i wasn't i was only partially
in control and i saw myself felt myself
going to a shop
to buy a shirt
and that was it
and i was
uh so annoyed with my brain because i
could have gone flying
i could have met a celebrity i've never
met i could have done all these amazing
things and instead my brilliantly
creative brain did a thing that i've
done many times in real life actually
really isn't very interesting
that is my only experience with lucid
dreaming uh so so i i love dreaming uh
and and i found it very helpful i just
can't get the lucid uh thing i used to i
know it's terrible i used to
have night terrors
i used to suffer from night terrors a
lot which if people don't know
it's where you sit up you've got your
eyes open normally it's about 90 minutes
into the night and you scream out and
you think there's a demonic entity there
or something like that and if you're
sleeping next to somebody else this
wakes them up and they're properly awake
at that point you yourself are still in
deep sleep and so you go straight back
to sleep and they're sitting up shaking
and going oh my goodness what's the
problem and they can't get back to sleep
at all so it's worse for them that is
for you
so yeah i did um had a lot of those for
a while and that's what got really
interesting to sleep i was thinking what
is going on in my little head that i
should that should see these demonic
entities
and well there's what's quite good about
having those is that
if you 90 minutes in you can't sleep and
you're a bit bored and you think well
you know let's make life a bit more
interesting from a partner you can sit
up and scream they wake up and then you
go back to sleep pretend you you had a
night terror
the upside of night terrors that's right
you're richard wiseman now that's that's
a great book title the upside tonight
terrorist is a great book title
so i
i do not frequently have nightmares but
i had a night terror a few nights ago
and i like woke up
screaming and scared the [ __ ] out of my
girlfriend who then
stiff-armed me like a reverse
clothesline
to try to keep me down because she's
afraid of me lashing out and kicking her
punching her because this happens every
six months or so yeah
it's a very very exciting evening i i
will say on the lucid dreaming side
in my senior year of high school i got
to the point where i could actually
i could actually
practice my sport at the time which was
a
let's call it olympic style wrestling in
the us would be collegiate style
wrestling
with a coach i'd never met at the time
it was john smith out of oklahoma who's
very very famous but i was actually able
to consistently
practice a skill
that transferred it seemed to have some
transference to the real world which i i
found
almost unbelievable
i'm sorry that yeah you were you're
buying a shirt and
it would be a bummer if i were to only
end up doing my taxes when i
induced lucidity but hold a second this
means that you can lucid dream
i can yeah but i i can lucid dream but i
will say that it is a very
perishable skill
if i do not
so i got to the point end of end of high
school and then transferring over to say
sophomore year in college
where i could
if i were journaling on a daily basis
immediately upon waking and
if you don't have any dream recall
trying to induce lucidity is pointless
largely so
those two seem to be closely correlated
or the development of one seems to be
closely correlated to the other
or i could induce lucidity
pretty consistently at least once a
night it becomes easier during longer
extended rem periods so let's just say
or very early morning which is why some
of the techniques have you wake up
around 4 am and then do a few things and
go back to bed but if i don't do the
journaling forget about it then it's
effectively non-existent
but if i end up so exhausted go ahead i
was going to say so my non-creative mind
sent me shirt shopping i suspect you do
far more interesting things in your
lucid dreams other than practicing sport
what what what do you do
oh you can fly around and have sex with
everybody those are kind of the two most
common
if people are developing this those are
where they usually self indulge the most
in the beginning my experience was in
the very early stages it was very
similar to your shirt buying experience
right you would have like a glimpse of
lucidity doing something really mundane
and then you would wake up or you would
slip back into non-lucid
sleep so it does seem to accrue and
there are
hopefully this doesn't make me sound
like a lunatic i think it's i mean it's
a very
for me at least through direct
experience like it's a very developable
skill
you can begin to extend your periods of
lucidity
using different techniques that seem to
have some reliable effect you know um
so it's
it is a skill that is of great interest
to me but it takes so much work
on the
journaling training side that i that
it's it's just generally not a super
high priority okay also waking up at
like four in the morning to
to increase the frequency is not very
appealing given that i already have
insomnia what else have you learned
about sleep and
improving sleep and why did you stop
having night terrors if you stopped yeah
i did they are related a little bit to
anxiety and also related to being a a
warm room so actually if you sleep in an
ice box essentially they they pretty
much go away
in terms of night terrors because you
mentioned your girlfriend they're so
worried about you lashing out
the the i think receive wisdom is not to
touch the person who's having the night
terror because they can interpret that
as being the demonic entity attacking
them and they will lash out
so keep your distance after just saying
the person's name gently
will will be so enough to bring them uh
kind of back i'll buy my girlfriend some
headgear and a mouthpiece she'll be fine
[Laughter]
says that in terms of the sleep stuff
there's all sorts of things you can do
to improve your quality of sleep one of
the biggest ones that came out of night
school which i didn't know about it was
if you've got kids who have recurrent
nightmares and this goes for adults as
well but particularly with kids
where it's the same nightmare
every night
during the day you get them to visualize
the nightmare but with a more positive
ending
so if they're being chased by a dragon
they visualize that and then you go
maybe it's a lonely dragon it's a
friendly dragon he just wants to be your
friend and actually that's got about a
90 hit rate within a very short period
of time for reducing those recurring
nightmares so there's all this kind of
simple stuff that's out there
i think all the stuff about this the
night of two halves and and actually
taking a break in the middle is what we
used to do before electric light and and
so on
the paradoxical if you're trying to fall
asleep the paradoxical approach which is
you try and keep yourself awake
so you're allowed to blink but otherwise
you have to keep your eyes open and you
have to actively not fall asleep it's
quite exhausting and you end up falling
asleep quicker again based on all sorts
of research so yeah night school was a
fun book to do
so then speaking to onset insomnia which
is something that i've suffered from for
decades and i go through periods of
not having it
be as a as acute an issue but the the
initial falling asleep portion for
people who don't understand the
terminology so there's the paradoxical
approach of
i've never tried the keeping my eyes
open part that that i haven't tried yeah
so i may try that yeah icebox i feel
like i've got that pretty well dialed
yeah use various devices to keep the bed
any other suggestions well there's
busying the mind if it's based on
anxiety so so just writing down those
anxieties and worries often clears it
before you you go to bed uh counting
backwards from 103's
phil's working memory basically uh and
it means that those anxieties can't get
in
engaging in
sort of
fantasy world so that when the dreams
and sleep comes along it's a little bit
more pleasant
and if you are laying there for more
than this is particularly waking up
during the night more than say 10
minutes waiting laying away from 10
minutes get out of bed and do something
non-stimulating but physical like one of
those kind of adult coloring in books
something like that do that for about 10
minutes go back to bed
if you're still laying there wait 10
minutes later get out and do it again
and after a couple of those
you start to fall asleep because what
happens is you what you're not doing is
associating the bed with the anxiety of
being awake otherwise that becomes a
stimulus response that other the bed is
a place where i'm anxious so moving
yourself out and occupying the mind and
going back again is another very
effective technique
what is your perspective
it came up earlier in this conversation
of
self-help book self-development books
and i know this is like a a
multi-faceted question maybe
several questions disguised as one the
figures in self-development are there
any any people in that world
you
admire are you largely skeptical of most
of it
how do you relate to it well i i got
into psychology partly through the magic
but also partly through dale carnegie
how to win friends and influence people
and how to stop worrying and start
living it pains me to say it because
it's another self-development author but
they are two of the greatest books ever
written and and now because they're
dated in terms of their language and so
on but the the concepts in there are
wonderful and very very simple and i'm a
bit fascinated by
carnegie and one of the things he did
was to go around the country giving
talks and what you've got in those books
are really the transcripts of the talks
so he didn't write them until he given
you know several hundred talks and was
was absolutely right that this was the
way to keep people's attention and so on
so he's wonderful
he also
did this great thing which was to keep a
diary
called damn stupid mistakes i've made
and every day he'd write did look think
back on the day anything about the
comment he wish he hadn't made or the
mistake he'd wished he hadn't done write
it down and then say right what would i
do tomorrow to stop that happening again
so it's the opposite of positive
journaling so he had all these these
ideas that the ideas in those books are
so simple and so wonderful and actually
now we're seeing the psychology to
support many of them so i'm a big fan of
of carnegie
and i think any self-development book if
it works for you then great my beef with
a lot of them is that even the
practitioners writing them don't believe
half this stuff and there's no
evidential known scientific underpinning
of it and yet you're asking people
who've got issues and
in their lives to go and make these
changes with no evidence at all
so i always say it's a bit like
if you've got a bad back you go to the
pharmacist and they say with some green
pills and you know there's evidence they
work and they go there not so much but
just you know take them see how it goes
well this would be crazy we wouldn't put
up with this for 10 seconds but we put
up with it within self-development so my
my mantra is always you know what is the
scientific underpinning of these ideas
although it sounds like there are also
cases with the practitioners or with
dale carnegie where it takes a while for
the science to catch up with the
practitioners so it's
it's uh i suppose it takes a level of
discernment and critical thinking to
be able to
trial and error on your own while also
understanding and respecting
the
sort of scientific method and all that
that reflects in terms of
lobby lobbying questions into the
universe and trying to secure answers a
la francis bacon carl popper and all
that you are right i mean sometimes
there's not the science there i guess
i'm talking about when there is the
science there and it doesn't support it
right but the other worry about them is
that if they are not effective
people go well they become very
fatalistic they go well you know i put
all the effort into whatever it was
visualization or whatever and it made no
difference there's nothing i can do and
so they could have a detrimental
impact
the reason i go into carnegie one the
thing is because i think it's in canada
i have to check now when i was a
teenager he had this great tip for
getting attractive people to sit next to
you on the bus
which was the uh which is a teenager
appealed to me immensely was that you
put your bag down next to you and as the
person's coming up the aisle just as
they reach where you are you pick up
your bag and move it onto your lap and
there's a huge social pressure on them
to come and sit in that seat
so i remember reading that when i was
like you know 17 or something i think oh
my goodness this psychology stuff is
very powerful
so
building on your mention of
carnegie's journaling the damn stupid
mistakes i've made or whatever it was
i want to ask you about the the luck
diary before before we get to that i
just want to say that how to stop
worrying and start living
is a book i've reread many times i
really recommend it to people if they
feel like they suffer from anxiety or
chronic worry it's a very practical book
what is the luck diary
lag diary came out of the luck work
which came out of a chance
happening
which was that
we were interviewing people as a friend
it wasn't my study was a colleague of
mine study
about key moments in their lives
choosing certain partners and and
careers and so on so i'm doing this
interview
for a colleague really about these these
things
and a couple of people i was
interviewing kept mentioning luck
that they would say i'm a really lucky
person already unlucky person or
whatever
at the time i studying paranormal belief
and i thought that's interesting because
luck beliefs are a bit like paranormal
stuff but there's been nothing done on
them and they're far more widespread and
so on so i spent about 10 years looking
at psychology of luck
and looking at the different ways in
which lucky and unlucky people think and
behave
and then we did a series of studies
where we tried to get people to change
their life to think and behave like a
lucky person and the luck diary was part
of that
and that really came from the gratitude
work
that all our sensory systems vision
everything works on habituation it works
it responds to change
and so if you like the smell of coffee
and you go into a coffee shop it'll
smell great for five minutes then
there's no change and you won't smell it
anymore you have to leave the shop to
come back in to smell it again
the same goes with many of the good
things in our lives the things that make
us happy our health our relationships
our family our career we get used to it
it vanishes
and that's one of the reasons why you
have this hedonistic treadmill you need
more and more and more to get that
feeling back
and what the luck diary does is does
that resetting it says to you every
night think about one thing which you
have a sense of gratitude or one
positive thing that happened today or
one negative thing that used to happen
that's no longer happening in your life
and it resets
that and and and focuses people's
attention on the positive and in doing
so changes their self-identity into a
luckier person which then kick-starts
all sorts of changes with their behavior
so it was it all came out of the lux
school work
i would imagine you know it's
helping train your selective attention
also by noting this each day right you
look back and after a week you have
seven examples
even if you generally have sort of a
melancholic
negative filter that you might use and i
speak from experience with that
that you start to see the counter
evidence accruing
for
for a different lens that you could use
yeah
you mentioned something and i may have
misheard you much earlier on that has
just been
on the back burner that i've wanted to
ask about did you say earlier that you
try not to have an idea before you walk
in a room or something about that
something along those lines it's the
opposite of what everyone says about
idea generation
which is that i found
there is something
i really don't recommend this for others
by the way it just seems to work for me
that
you you know what the meeting is about
so let's suppose it's gonna be a new tv
show you know they want some ideas for a
new game show
you can overthink it
and there is something about putting
that on the back burner letting it
incubate
and then when you walk into that room
that's in my experience when you have
the best idea
or when you wake up sometimes but
normally so so with the the laugh lab
which is where it came up
it was only walking into the room i
suddenly thought we should do find the
world's funniest joke it's a risky old
strategy
but he has paid off for me uh time and
again
can you tell
the world's funniest joke i can't
believe i dropped
that baton is that something you're you
can share on the on the podcast that's
something you refer people to so here's
the thing i did that in
the year 2000 so it's whatever it is 20
something years of telling the world's
funniest joke
first of all it's not the world's
funniest joke it's the world's blandest
joke because the joke that appealed to
most people
second the second we took out all the
rude jokes which were far funnier than
the uh
the more polite ones
and third i've told it so many times
that what i say to people is it is all
over the web
go and have a look and then you can read
it and not laugh in your own time
because if i tell it to you there'll be
such social pressure on you to laugh
that i'll i just feel really kind of
awkward about the entire thing
so it involves two hunters in a wood
that's all i'm prepared to say at this
point
okay people can search your name
funniest joke two hunters i imagine
that'll be specific enough to get them
on the right track that will do it that
will do it yes
do you feel certain facets of your work
could be applied in schools for instance
or education in any way yeah i'm quite
passionate about this i mean
it's it's phenomenal isn't it that we
teach
kids so much stuff that is so
unbelievably useless to them in the rest
of their lives
and we don't teach them anything
that is actually kind of useful
uh in terms of the psychology so you
think well we know this stuff about
resilience
and relationships and happiness and all
these important topics
and yet it's still certainly in the uk a
very fact-based curriculum to do with
you know geography and history and all
this sort of thing not say we shouldn't
be teaching that stuff of course we
should but
you know there's all these life skills
which for the most part we don't teach
kids
and i think the challenge is finding a
vehicle for it i mean some of my work at
the moment is looking at teaching kids
magic because actually magic tricks
teach many of these things you know
you've got to learn to practice you've
got to learn to follow instructions
you've got to perform which means having
you know thinking about the audience and
and so on you've got to deal with
negative feedback you'll be getting a
lot of that as a magician
and so
you know that that being a vehicle for i
think is is quite helpful but yeah
absolutely this stuff needs to be out
there in schools
have you tried that or or would you try
it in the form of a seminar or once
weekly experiment kind of dale carnegie
style workshopping
some of these things yeah i think
teaming up with effective teachers i've
never done teaching so i'm sure there's
all sorts of things that one could learn
but absolutely
and i think it'd be a question of
finding that vehicle because
i think you've got to do something that
connects i think as adults we understand
how important those skills are i'm not
certain children do
but if you could find that vehicle that
that framing that wrap around that
engaged them i i think it'd be wonderful
i'd like to just read a
short paragraph from a piece in the new
yorker which says wiseman whose career
has ranged from professional magician to
professor of the public understanding of
psychology at the university of
hertfordshire hartfordshire
we talked about this before
before we recorded i can't get it
delight in demystifying magic and other
mind deceptions of all the tricks he
demystified during the evening the
audience favorite was called the yale
goal study
and i was wondering if you could
describe that describe the yale goal
study why that why do you think that was
a favorite
yeah so that's the
yale motivation study which is this
wonderful thing
which is that the researchers go
apparently from yale i think it's
harvard actually and maybe harvard or
yeah i can't remember which one
university researchers
go to a school they ask kids what you
want to be when you grow up only about
three percent of the kids know what they
want to be they return 20 something
years later and track them down and that
three percent in terms of the income of
the entire cohort they represent about
70 80 percent of the income
i.e is a really good idea to focus young
in terms of financial well-being later
on
so i read that
great sticking to 59 seconds wonderful
better track down the reference though i
always tried to get to original sources
on papers couldn't find it i asked my
colleagues to work in those kind of
areas they had never read that paper
eventually i figured out and other
people figured out it's never been run
it's a complete myth it's all over the
web it's in many self-development books
it's in lots of talks it doesn't exist
there is no evidence
that focusing that young
has that kind of impact financially
and that's why i mean about the
importance of asking for that that
evidence it's it's astonishing
you know what makes it all the more
astonishing is how specific
the description is of this supposed yell
goal study right in 1953 team of
researchers interview and um shortening
here but interviewed graduating seniors
asking them blah blah did they have
specific goals and then they tracked
them down however but 20 years later and
the 3 percent who had specified their
goals had accumulated more personal
wealth than the other 97 percent
combined it's very specific yes right
and the reason why it's not it's odd is
that that's a longitudinal study and and
so tracking down that group of kids is
not going to be easy that's going to be
a well-known paper you know it's very
difficult to track cohorts over that
kind of time period so i i thought oh
two seconds work to find it and then you
go oh my goodness that's that's that's
just not out there
well you know what happens too very
often more and more so these days with
technology is you have these
sort of recursive self-reinforcing
myths uh for instance i'll give an
example there's this there's this effect
sometimes it's called the wikipedia echo
effect so let's just say someone puts
this example
in
fill in the blank media outlet and they
don't have fact checkers and they don't
really want to do the heavy lifting of
trying to ascertain whether it's true or
not they just assume it's true because
it's all over the internet
and then somebody puts that into
wikipedia with a citation
and then
you can see how suddenly there's this
snowball effect of citation but there's
actually no original work
that proves
or
demonstrates any clear evidence for this
so you you find also a lot of factual
inaccuracies
on wikipedia that becomes
self-perpetuating in that way because as
soon as there's one citation
then it encourages other
outlets
to use the same material and on and on
we go on the merry-go-round yeah so yeah
track down if you can those original
sources and i mean often studies do
exist and you find out that
what it's like come
the description of it's been passed on
from one person to another and it's been
sharpened up over time so by the end you
get this wonderful study when you look
it back at the original there's nothing
like the study that you're reading about
even if that study did exist so
absolutely yeah that's the importance of
going back to original sources
so let me take a look at i'm pulling it
up right now one of my favorite quotes
which is from the physicist richard
feynman
the first principle is that you must not
fool yourself and you are the easiest
person to fool
and i bring that up because of several
things the first is you mentioned a lot
of these folks who are
purportedly using
psychic powers or uh
able to produce sci phenomena
are not fakes in the sense that they
disbelieve what they are doing right
they believe what they are doing
another way though that we could
look at a an example of maybe maybe an
example of fooling one oneself is the
construction or reconstruction and
memory
could you speak to
the malleability of people's
testimonies i'm just wondering
if you have other examples that you can
pull from and certainly in police
investigations you see this constantly
cinematically rashaman is a pretty good
example
but i'd love to to hear you explore that
in any way that makes sense it just
seems that memory is
less reliable perhaps than people would
think at first glance
i think both observation and memory so
the impression that we get
is that
we're good observers we wouldn't miss
something big in front of us happening
right in front of us and second our
memories are are pretty accurate and if
you learn anything about
cognitive psychology at all is that both
those things are
just simply not true
so there's all these studies into what's
called inattentional blindness where you
know big things happen right in front of
you and the dan simon's basketball video
for folks that i know i'm talking about
as a wonderful example of it i did think
of the color changing card trick on
youtube was the first quarkology video
we did actually where you don't notice
all these changes that are happening
around you
so the way in which observation actually
works
is that it's incredibly clever you know
if you were taking all the information
coming at you all the time you just need
to brain the size of the planet
so your brain focuses on what it thinks
is the most important thing
and
then if other stuff changes you don't
spot that
so we are very selective observers is
the first part
and second when it comes to memory
it's not like replaying a film or a
videotape instead you have these kind of
fragments and you try and create a
narrative around it
and the place i see that most frequently
is actually when people describe magic
tricks so you perform a magic trick they
then tell their friends what's happened
it's nothing like the thing they've just
seen
and in fact the problem is their friend
said will show me and now you're about
to do something which was completely
different to the the description they've
just had from their their other friend
so
yeah we we create this narrative often
if we're being interviewed by somebody
they can suggest details to us
just some studies on paranormal key
bending where you put a bent key down on
the table and the psychic says look you
still can see it's still bending and
around about 40 percent of people say
they can see the key still bending
uh with the seance work again about 40
50 percent of people would go with the
suggestions of the medium oh my goodness
the table is levitating now and they've
come out and swear they saw the table
levitate
so our memory
is very malleable
as we try and remember fragments and
create a plausible kind of story that's
how it all works
and of course what's terrifying is that
often within the legal system that's not
realized by juries and they go well
there's a very confident witness there
they wouldn't have missed something big
in front of them or they must be
remembering what happened there's no
evidence that's the case
yeah it's terrifying it's totally
terrifying
it's just uh which
thankfully there there are initiatives i
think it's called the innocence project
which is focused on sort of dna-based
exoneration
i'm sure somebody in the
responses to this podcast will will fact
check that if if necessary but
it is it is both
deeply interesting right because of the
sort of
cognitive reconstruction that can go on
and the
power of suggestibility to see the
fallibility of observation and memory
and it's deeply deeply troubling also
when you think about some of the
ramifications but what's funny about it
is we all suffer from this kind of
uniqueness by us we think oh it's other
people that aren't observant it's other
people that don't remember stuff and and
i mean you know i've done loads of these
studies i still find it hard to get into
my head that would be me thinking the
table levitated or the key ben
so we we all like to think it's it's
everybody else's problem it's it's us as
much as them we're all very very similar
in that regard
are there any
scientists researchers investigators
however you want to to look at it who
you consider smart
and largely
rational who study
i mean i just didn't even use the terms
because obviously the connotations are
so negative but psi phenomena or a
meta-analyses of the of such or
touch on any edge of that because
i'd just be curious to know if there any
any folks who come to mind where you're
like yeah i actually respect these
people i think they're smart and yet
they risk career suicide by
digging into these things well the
reason i'm laughing is that one room
that way is professor caroline watt who
is my partner who runs the edinburgh
parapsychology unit at edinburgh
university so she's a parapsychologist
and and
as far as i know i could go and check
but as far as i know she's a fairly
reliable and honest uh researcher so
it's interesting cause i'm very
skeptical and caroline's a bit more open
and we've been together for 20 something
years
we don't actually discuss the topic very
much we
you know so get on with living rather
than um argue endlessly about whether
psy exists so uh so i think caroline
would have to be on my list
but i think i see most most of people
interested
in it and and uh straightforward it's a
bit like the
the psychics
you know there's all sorts of problems
that can creep into experiments where
you end up fooling yourself you don't
need to be dishonest you just end up
doing an experiment it's not very well
controlled and you want to get a
positive result and that's what you see
in your data
and that's happening in psychology as
well
and what's happening within mainstream
psychology is there's all sorts of
checks and balances coming in place now
that weren't there even five years ago
and a thing called pre-registration
which is where you write down how you're
going to analyze your data before you've
collected it and we're seeing some of
those effects starting to fade away
exactly the same is happening in
parapsychology
and so daryl beam who he mentioned right
this the start you know he to his credit
ran two very large-scale studies into
that idea that people could look into
the future
pre-registered them so he couldn't do
sniff around in his data
null effects nothing there at all
so it this is a challenging time i think
for parapsychology and for for
psychology
let's just say you know i i happen to be
in in the uk and i said
let's grab a couple bottles of wine and
was it carolyn or caroline i never know
caroline so let's say caroline joined us
and we we all split a couple bottles of
wine and i said all right caroline
what is what is richard
missing or what are his biases like why
why do you think you guys are so
seemingly on to kind of opposite ends of
the spectrum here what would she say do
you think obviously you're not speaking
for her but just well i could go and ask
her
what would she say
it depends whether i'm sitting there or
not i think if i'm sitting there i
should tell you there's no biases at all
and i'm a lovely lovely lovely person
okay it's a one-on-one it's a like it's
a one-on-one you've still got the three
bottles of wine between the two of you
uh then
i think
she would say that she's genuinely
curious about some of these anomalies in
the data i don't think she's totally i
can't speak for her but i don't think
she's convinced that psy exists i think
she's just curious and and wants to see
more well-controlled research so to that
end she's won the people that set up a
pre-registration within parapsychology
so a place where you can say this is
what i intend to do this is how i'm
going to analyze my data and you you
give that all over those details over
before you run your study that's that's
part of her work so i i think she'd fall
into the i'm curious category rather
than i'm convinced by the existence of
of psy
i just want to underscore how important
if people aren't familiar with the
concept of pre-registration how
incredibly important this is
uh
for all of science
i had a follow-up question about that
why do you think there are these people
who dedicate i mean
understanding that yes partially could
be due to curiosity but are willing to
kind of peg their careers to something
that is so difficult or
so difficult to prove in a lab or
demonstrate in a lab i shouldn't even
say proof right just to show
a significant effect
in a properly controlled
trial of of any type why why do you
think they do that oh i know many of
them very well i was in the field for
sort of 10 15 years the answer is
because they've normally had an
inexplicable experience
that something has happened to them
and with paranormal experiences if you
believe they're genuinely paranormal my
goodness this might be the most
important experience of your entire life
you saw into the future
you know you had a telepathic
communication with somebody many miles
away
this is life-changing stuff because if
that's true our fundamental assumptions
about the entire universe are completely
wrong
and and so yes they're often into the
science
but they're driven by that some sort of
personal experience it's not to say the
bad scientists because of it but i think
that's what keeps them going
as that notion there's going to be a
breakthrough and we're going to finally
understand this intangible thing that is
psy
so let me jump to an area where
i i don't believe they they use
scythe phenomena quite as much and that
is nasa to my knowledge so the the
apollo moon landings i'm reading here
that you've studied the psychology used
by the mission controllers involved in
those moon landings
why how did you end up looking at that
and why did you find it
why did you find it compelling
again so many things happen on a chance
basis so i go to a party
which is quite a rare occurrence for me
for reasons that are probably apparent
now uh having chatted to you for quite a
long time so i invited to a party i end
up in a kitchen i'm speaking to a friend
of mine helen keane who's really into
space stuff
and at the time it was the sort of 50th
anniversaries of of landing on the moon
and she was talking about the amazing
technology that came off of the
apollo missions
and i said well has anyone looked at the
amazing psychology that came off it
because at the time
putting somebody on the moon was pretty
it was the closest thing you could get
to an impossible
event by the end of the decade within
you know sort of eight years or so of it
being announced as a
goal
and she said oh no i i don't think so
but
you have to speak to the mission
controllers they sat at the heart of the
operation
and nasa and i said well how would i do
that and she said well you could speak
to my friend craig
he's he's fanatical about nasa he's
befriended most of them so i spoke to
craig
who and then kindly put me in touch with
the mission controllers as i say the
people that sat at the heart of this
mission
and they're astonishing group of people
that basically achieved the impossible
and what is remarkable about them is
whereas the astronauts are a very
particular type of person you know it's
a credible selection procedure and so on
the mission controllers are almost the
opposite
they at the time were incredibly young
average age about 21 when they start wow
i mean unbelievable that's young even
when neil armstrong walks on the moon
average age in mission control 28 you
know it's it's it's unbelievable
second they're the first in their
families to go to university
they are not from the you know ivory
league
universities they're mainly from rural
backgrounds across america
and the reason for that is they really
wanted a group of people who are
passionate because they knew what i was
saying that were
quote one of them jerry bostick so young
they didn't know it couldn't be done
and so they went in with this spirit of
of course we can do it and also they're
team players
they use their problem solvers they
don't want to be individual stars and
everyone i spoke to is extremely modest
and humble about their contribution
but they they would pull together as a
team and they would solve any problem
that was thrown at them
and and so i really got into this
this this mode of trying to understand
the mindset that put us
on the moon because i think it's one of
our greatest achievements pretty much
seen as impossible and yet these folks
sat at the heart of it i mean obviously
hundreds of thousands of people involved
in that putting it all together but
these were the the people at the heart
of it
it was astonishing
and so yeah i did shoot for the moon or
moonshot as it's called in america which
unpacks the psychology of that
who is now i'm looking at for those who
can't see any visual here i'm looking
behind you and you have a number of
things on top of your bookshelf
who is the looks like a gentleman in a
black and white photo
behind you i have absolutely no idea
this is just like masterpiece theater
the reason it's there
is a magician friend came to stay with
me i would think a year ago something
like that
he goes to a antique shop and he sees
the picture that's sitting up there
and he comes back and he says richard
put that on your mantelpiece behind you
and i said why and he said because when
you're doing zoom calls people will ask
who it is
well you got me just like moving the
handbag i sat down next to you you guys
don't feel bad
it's almost everyone asks who it is i've
absolutely no idea i think it's an
acrobatic dancer um it's a lovely lovely
picture um but i wish i could say you
know wonderful story about it but um i
can't say all right so well it seems
like you're giving people three options
to hang themselves so i'm gonna ask
about what looks like a door knocker
what is that in the middle is there that
is a very very expensive um i'm giving
away some secrets here magic prop ah
so
on a good day not the minute but on a
good day it knocks on its own
and we used it in a lot of seances
and now when kids come around the house
i tell them the house is haunted which
might be the case actually it's quite an
old house haunted and that occasionally
the ghost will make their presence known
by knocking on this
and then i turn my back and this knocks
and the kids go oh my goodness i said no
it didn't it's just your imagination and
then that goes on for you know maybe 20
30 minutes
and then the kids say who's the picture
next to it i go i have no idea who that
is
well at least i'm going uh going in the
opposite direction from the kids but
still on the same page makes me feel
good child at heart as like as i
continually say so i'll just just a few
more questions richard i really
appreciate you taking the time
so this this question sometimes is a
dead end and i'll take the blame if
that's the case but
let's say you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking you could put
any message any quote any photograph
anything at all
on it to get the attention of billions
of people
what might you put on that billboard
off the top of my head this is a
terrible answer i would go back to
carnegie i would go back to simplicity
and i would just put the word smile
that's it
or maybe something that would make them
smile
because
it's it's phenomenal what's this is what
carnegie says what smiling does
you know it it means it's reciprocated
by the other person and they say they
feel good when they're around you
and and so on
and right now obviously it's a very
stressful time for lots of people in
lots of ways so i think i'd just go with
something unbelievably simple
like that and then if it didn't work out
and people went oh that's a really bland
thing to say i would blame it on
carnegie
[Laughter]
i always have an exit strategy good
advice
besides your own books are there any
books that you
gift often or recommend often to other
people no
uh you don't even get my books just a
gift um you've got to pay full price for
them uh no no um
i uh again i in terms of
self-development stuff i i go with
carnegie i mean i just think it's it's
very hard to to beat
that's present more generally
i don't actually
because i read
so much uh for work i don't read very
much for pleasure at all i mean this
this room is just full of books and
they're all non-fiction psychology books
for the most part because that's that's
what i i kind of read
so i don't read that much outside of
that
i would say
in terms of
say films or something like that i mean
james randy's honest liar is a great
great documentary
and and that was a lot of fun to to kind
of work on i knew randy very very well
and many many
fun i was standing we
um we were both giving talks together in
italy and i was standing outside the
venue and randy came up and he said oh
richard
i've got some stories to tell you i've
been looking forward to meeting you and
he told me all these wonderful stories
all very funny about testing psychics
and so on and he said thank you very
much for listening and i said okay and
then he walked on stage and he told all
the same stories with exactly the same
beats and the wording i realized i've
just been in a rehearsal space for him
i'd miss randy hugely charismatic and so
much fun to be around so that's great
and what else do i like terms of film
man on wire man and why are these
brilliant it has to be one of the
greatest documentaries ever made because
it's that same thing we get back to the
apollo mission controllers which is how
do you achieve the impossible you know
how do you even have the idea of
creating the impossible let alone going
about and doing it oh my goodness if
there's any inspirational film for me
it's that one
man on wire yeah i will also say this
this won't give away any detail but
we've been talking about at different
points in this conversation or you've
been mentioning
charlatans frauds of different types
whether they're doing it knowingly or or
unknowingly
and
if it's a fake seance perhaps the the
damage might be minimal but there are
charlatans out there who do a lot of
damage and
there are a few case studies
and showcases of that in an honest liar
and
i thought it was not just really
compelling material and an amazing story
with lots of twists and turns definitely
folks should watch the trailer but also
a service in a way
to to make people just a bit more not
cynical but skeptical of what is
immediately presented before them
because some charlatans do a tremendous
tremendous amount of of damage
yeah i mean
the flip side of that which randy
recognized as well is of course there
are people out there claiming psychic
stuff who actually do quite a lot of
good i mean going along and talking
about your problems and issues with
somebody's empathic and cares and so on
is no bad thing
you know if you've lost a loved one
so human to want to be in touch with
them and if you're sending them one last
message and that film makes you feel
better via a medium but you know
who am i to be critical so
it is
you know one has to have a nuanced
approach to this as you say absolutely
there are frauds and charlatans who do
not care one jot about the emotional or
physical well-being of their audiences
and they're just in it for the fame and
money equally there are other people who
probably are not
fraught faking it in that way
who care deeply about the the people in
front of them so it's it's a it's a
complicated area
i'll give one
just tech insight for folks who may be
tempted to work with mediums and if you
feel so inclined go crazy but i was
watching this
this snippet of a tv show
of some celebrity medium
and you know the claim was my producers
don't let me know anything about these
people at all
except for
i get to see a photograph that's it just
a photograph and i just want to point
out to people that one of the things you
can do with a photograph
is you can take that photograph and do a
reverse
google image search and find social
profiles of someone and then gather
information that way so just
uh be aware of that so that if you
decide to work with someone and you
really want to stress test them
having them start with a blank slate do
not provide any images
any other documentaries that come to
mind i'm i'm i'm on the market for new
documentaries could be television series
there's one i'm interested in watching i
haven't watched it yet so
it might be terrible for anyone
listening but it's called bad vegan and
it's about a
uh restaurateur who is
seduced into marrying a con artist who
claims he can make her dog immortal and
it's supposed to be just spectacular
television
has all the ingredients necessary
but do any any other documentaries
could be about magicians could be about
anything at all
tv shows come to mind for you well
richard turner's documentary is
wonderful i think you mentioned it is
great dealt i mean i've watched a whole
load of documentaries about magic and
they're they're all kind of fun and give
you i mean we have this
kind of idea that show business is is so
kind of glossy and great because all we
see is just that moment on stage when it
all looks wonderful and in fact it's one
of the hardest ways to make a living and
it's it's terrible in all sorts of ways
there's several documentaries uh on
magic that um give that out i enjoyed
there was one about
cert slay and the selection process on
search slay oh amazing which i really
enjoyed recently just in terms of the
sheer that hard work that goes into that
when i was
oh far too young 17 16 17 i did flying
trapeze
and so i i mean i say i did it i went to
ten lessons to do it
and
i it's extremely difficult i've got to
say
and b i learnt a lot because it's so
obviously dangerous that none of us
messed around and none of us thank
goodness got injured
next in was clown school
and they'd all bundle in and they sort
of push each other over and actually
it's really easy to like chip an elbow
or something if you don't know what
you're doing so every
every week it was the clowns that got
injured and never the flying japanese
people
usually satisfied
oh i will find the title of the cirque
du soleil selection process documentary
and i'll put that in the show notes for
folks so you'll be able to find that in
the show that's ringing of fire or
something like that
yeah and
to your point
on show business
i i every time i watch a
television special or a documentary that
is based on a live show and they mention
the the sheer volume
of shows it always
is mind-blowing and mind-numbing on on a
certain level i remember watching
miracle by darren brown which i think is
fantastic and for people interested i
think it's a fair description to say
that
darren gets on stage says i have no
special powers but i've sort of studied
the techniques of preachers and
so on around the country around the
world and i'm going to give you
demonstrations of faith healing and
there's a lot more to it it's a
spectacular show i've seen it twice but
in the beginning it says something just
like in and of itself you know this show
was performed 578 times
in such and such a theater
and
that
now why do you think
someone like darren i don't know darren
personally we've had a few exchanges but
or anyone
does that it just seems
so physically and mentally punishing
to do
to even approach that is there anything
that you've seen as patterns in in
personality or anything that
leads people to do that it's a very
interesting question isn't it because
yeah you have to go out and do the same
thing every single night i mean it's
even worse i suspect for actors because
at least darren's got some kind of
freedom in in what he says and how he
interacts with people and so on
my guess would be
that's just an enormous adrenaline rush
to see that standing ovation which every
time i've seen darren you know he gets
and like all the other vegas performers
do
to change your question slightly what i
find fascinating is how you keep it
fresh
i mean how because there's nothing worse
than watching a performer that's dialing
it in and because you need to feel this
is the first time you know it's been
done it's being done for you right and i
spoke to a couple of performers about
that and one of the techniques that one
of them i should probably shouldn't
mention the name but one of them used
very experienced performer
was to stand in the wings
and to go you know there'll come a time
when i'm too old to do this
or i'm not physically able to
or the audiences don't want to see me
anymore and that would be i'll be very
very sad because i won't be able to do
it and they let that moment sink in
and then they go
it's not tonight though
and out they go
[Music]
and it's a wonderful example of what
we're talking about before i'm not
getting that habituation get to you you
know it's it's saying this is going to
go at some point so make tonight count
it's it's a great it's one of my
favorites and i do i mean i give talks i
don't perform like that but the luck
talk i've given hundreds and hundreds of
times and i'll often do that in the
wings just to go at some point people
want to hear this talk not tonight
though
oh that is fantastic i really really
love that well richard uh this has been
uh
very fun i've really enjoyed this
conversation is there anything else that
you would like to mention any closing
comments
any complaints you'd like to lodge
any requests to my audience not that i
mean anything at all
no you've made it such a joy thank you
very much
i i suppose the only thing if you look
back at all this stuff we've been
talking about i think the one thing that
underlies it all is a fascination with
the impossible you know whether it's
paranormal whether it's magic whether
it's what the apollo folks did whether
it's luck
trying to change people's lives i'm just
fascinated by how we do something
that we ourselves or others considered
to be impossible and you know the moment
you do it everyone else goes well that
was obvious of course you could do that
and and i i think that's been the
driving force through uh all this work
if if there is one but no thank you very
much and and thank you for making it
such a joy oh my pleasure hopefully we
have a round two and maybe we'll even
get to that that that that three bottle
of wine dinner at some point
on twitter
at richard wiseman
what is is your youtube channel also
richard wiseman or does it go by
different youtube channel is quirkology
oh quirkology as in quirky psychology
yeah
all right and we will link to all these
things in the show notes everybody
listening we will have links to all
references everything that we discussed
at team.blog podcast as per usual
and until next time thank you for tuning
in
you